robert spencer iran's appointed and then
elected president
is not a murderer he's a mass murderer
and there's no
doubt about the crimes he's committed
and yet
all of europe is congratulating this new
president
what in the world are they thinking
well i'm not sure that thinking and
europe really go together anymore
uh the when you have the leaders of
europe all they're looking at is the
bottom line
they want to do business with iran they
want iranian oil they want other
ties with iran and so they're willing to
put up with anything
and the iranians seeing the weakness in
washington the weakness of biden sanders
administration
they are making
they are providing the foundation
for somebody like raisi to become
president of iran
if we had a strong president in the
white house
then there might have been a moderate
conciliatory
president chosen in iran but because we
have weakness
in the white house they chose a strong
aggressive individual who's going to to
to
advance iran's interests as far as he
possibly can